how should the sabbath
be kept well the bible gives this
sabbath
gives us some serious clues and after
yes
isaiah 58 13 and 14 let me pray again
father as we continue answering
questions give us wisdom
wisdom take god that the truth may be
properly represent
and you glorified and your people
blessed in jesus name i pray
amen if thou turn away thy foot from the
sabbath
from doing thy pleasure on my holy day
and call the sabbath a delight the holy
of the lord honorable and shall honor
him
not doing thine own ways not finding
their own pleasures nor speaking their
own words and so we have don't do
your own activities don't find your own
pleasures don't speak your own words
which means
the bible is telling us our conversation
must be different on the sabbath
our activities must be different what we
consider delightful and pleasurable must
be different
there must be some holy pleasures that
are fit for the sabbath
and not the secular pleasures which we
have during the week which may be fine
for the week
and so isaac 50 13 14 gives us
some clues now if you go to uh
the commandment itself exodus 28-11
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt now labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god in it
thou shalt not do any work so we know
avoid work
and anything related to work now since
you must be careful with your words
words proceed from how we think
our very thinking must change on the
sabbath our thoughts must be occupied
that which is holy but this requires
practice and discipline
yes i said discipline the mind can be
disciplined
to focus on only that which is holy on
the sabbath day
so that i do not sit at home or in the
church view on sabbath
thinking of the office work waiting for
me on monday or sunday
this is not sabbath keeping so sabbath
keeping is that careful effort to make
sure
that in speech in action and thinking
in all that i do i am reflecting my
awareness of the extreme
holiness of this day and i use the word
extreme because the holiness of the
sabbath
is the holiness of god the bible says
the law and the commandment is holy
just and good what is that holiness the
holiness of god
and the holiness of god is present in
the sabbath day commandment
as it is not in other days the other
days are not holy they're secular i'm
not saying they curse
they're just not holy the seventh day is
holy
the words holy hallowed and blessed are
used
only with respect to the fourth
commandment now
keeping this in mind recognizing who the
creator is
we guard our behavior on this day
when i was a little boy and ellen white
tells us to do this we would cove we
would turn magazines over so you
couldn't see the cover page
we turned them down because what you see
can affect your thinking
we would put a a sort of a towel to
cover the television screen
we would do that remove your site
anything that would
he would do that as children we were
taught to do that we had to get our
clothes ready on friday
your shoes polished we did all of that
because that day is so serious god is
assigned an
entire day of preparation now that tells
you how serious that day is in the sight
of god
he is assigned an entire day called the
preparation day
now that day is not holy but the sabbath
has
a day attached to it called preparation
day
and so when you keep all of this in mind
you realize
everything on that day must be an
expression of holy behavior which flows
from holy thinking
which is possible by keeping the mind on
a holy god
and you do that by going to the holy
word
amen thank you so much members of the
church must be taught how to keep the
sabbath
let me digress a little bit i'm not sure
what time it is let me check my
oh just four minutes left can i have 10
more minutes yes you can take as much
time as you'd like i'll escape
the law is righteousness all the
commandments of righteousness we're told
in psalm 119 verse 172 i think it is
verse 144 and verse 141
now i want 42. now righteousness is
something that must be taught it is not
something that
just happens because you're sitting in a
church listen to second timothy chapter
3 verse 16.
all scripture is given by inspiration of
god and is profitable
for doctrine for reproof for correction
and for instruction in righteousness
righteousness is some it is not simply a
quality of god
which it is but it is a lifestyle it's a
way of behaving
it's a way of speaking it's a way of
thinking and the bible says
it has to be taught listen to christ
matthew 28 18 to 20 and jesus came and
spake unto them saying
all power is given unto me in heaven and
in earth
boy therefore and teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son
and of the holy ghost teaching them to
observe what does that mean
people must be taught how to obey
teaching them to observe
all things whatsoever i have commanded
you
and all that god has commanded us is
summed up in the ten commandments
because the bible says
ecclesiastes 12 13 this is the whole
duty of man from commandment 1
to commandment 10 members need to be
taught
how to obey god how to obey the second
commandment not to have idols
how to obey the six not to kill how to
obey the sabbath commandment to keep it
holy
because god made it holy but you must
keep it holy
and the question must be answered how
do i keep it holy i know how god made it
holy
but how do i keep it holy and the bible
plus the blessed counsel from ellen
white gives us a lot of information
and church leaders should make it the
business to regularly
instruct the church in how to keep the
sabbath holy
because my guess is without benefit of a
survey
millions of adventists have no clue how
to keep the sabbath holy other than
don't go to work
and there's more this happens keeping
and don't go to work because if don't go
to work instead of keeping
every unemployed person is a sabbath
keeper
and that's not the case
all right thank you for that
yes yes in fact the other part of the
question that the person asked was
how does a person keep from being bored
so what do we do
after worship is over this is the other
part of the question
forgive me for laughing you see
someone who loves basketball is never
bored by basketball
are you with me someone who loves
football is
not bored by football a
christian who's bored with a holy
activity then my question has to be wait
a minute wait a minute
how can you be bored with something that
is
natural to the converted person
the study of the word of god changes our
tastes let me say that again
the study of the word of god changes
our tastes changes how we think changes
how we respond to spiritual requirements
so that boredom goes out the window when
we have the word of god
when we have access to the materials of
hell and white when we have
access to fellowship one with the other
to encourage one another
when we have nature all around us
because god
is expressed first through christ and
his followers in the bible
of course nature was the first book
before the bible came along
so there are ample opportunities to
fight
against boredom but the cornerstone
against spiritual boredom
is a genuine conversion to jesus christ
and his standard of righteousness a
genuine conversion
will make bible study church fellowship
spiritual things
your greatest joy that's why jesus
christ when he was talking to the woman
at the well john chapter 4
she went to the village to tell the good
news the disciples brought some food
in verse 31 of john 4 the bible says
that
me at the same time his disciples prayed
him saying master e
they knew he was hungry he said i have
meat to eat you know not off
he was so absorbed with trying to save
the woman that food meant little to him
you see because his his mind was
spiritual
everything was spiritual when we have
the mind of christ
and that has to be developed spiritual
things become
a joy there's no such thing as i've
heard people say
what will i do in heaven or the new
world never never die i'll be born sick
no you won't be born sick
you will not be bored sick in heaven it
will be your greatest joy
a total and a constant surrender of the
life to jesus
is the defense against boredom because
then spiritual things
become your spiritual joy that's why the
bible says of jesus i
delight to do thy will or my god yeah
thy law is
in my heart what's in the heart is done
joyfully
david said in psalm 119 verse 97
oh how love i thy law it is my
meditation all the day i love the ten
commandments listen to ellen white the
christ object lessons page 97 paragraph
three
the man who attempts to keep the
commandments of god from a sense of
obligation merely
because he's required to do so will
never enter into the joy of obedience
he does not obey when the commandments
of god are accounted a burden
because they cut across human
inclination we may know
that the life is not a christian life
true obedience is the outworking of a
principle within
it springs from the love of
righteousness the love of the law of god
the essence of all righteousness is
loyalty to our redeemer
this will lead us to do right because it
is right because right doing is pleasing
to god
ask god to put love in your heart
for his law and for righteousness
but the bible is the most exciting book
to the person
whose mind has been changed there's no
such thing as boredom in christ
how can you be bored by the creator who
just spake
and the entire universe came how can
that be boring
you